regional flood control district says our
valleys detention bases and washes
work the way they're supposed to work
that's right as monsoon season continues
we're taking a closer look at the system
and what's ahead
a dry pitman wash near eastern and
pebble after mother nature's furry
caused havoc around the valley now crews
are left to clear the debris left behind
the storm channels the storm drains and
the detention basins did a great job of
moving the water from the west side of
town to the east side of town safely
michelle french is with the regional
flood control district and says the goal
of the system is to keep the water away
from the people and the properties the
regional flood control district has 222
flood threat recognition systems to tell
our hydrologists and our engineers on
staff
how much water is actually raining in
that particular location to the west the
tropicana detention basin near russell
and decatur was cleared after a busy
flow overnight the regional flood
control district tweeting the water
depth has risen to over 16 feet still
lots of capacity
since the mid-1980s about 680 miles of
storm channels and over 100 detention
basins have been built taxpayers have
spent 2.16 billion dollars and improved
more than 60 miles of land removed from
flood zones every time it rains we're
scared magnolia magot owns this cafe
near eastern and pebbles and says
flooding is a constant headache for them
they hope flood control crews can
complete the 47 pending projects around
the valley to ease her worries the roads
right here
they get flooded
well the flood district is asking for
the public's help during monsoon season
they are asking residents to report any
debris or clogged storm drains or
channels and we've set up a direct link
on our website 8newsnow.com